How long do you think it will take before
machines do your job better than you
do?
Automation used to mean
big stupid machines doing
repetitive work in factories
today. They can learn their craft,
diagnose cancer and trade stocks.
We are entering a new age of automation
unlike anything that's come before.
According to a 2013 study,
almost half of all jobs in the u s could
potentially be automated in the next
two decades, but wait, it hasn't
automation been around for decades.
What's different this time?
The things you used to be simple.
Innovation made human work
easier and productivity rose,
which means that more staff for services
could be produced per hour using the
same amount of human workers.
This eliminated many jobs but also
created other jobs that were better,
which was important because of the
growing population needed work.
So in a nutshell, innovation,
higher productivity,
fewer old jobs and many
new and often better jobs.
Overall, this worked well for a majority
of people and living standards improved.
There's a clear progression in terms
of what humans did for a living.
For the longest time we
worked in agriculture with
the industrial revolution.
This shifted to production jobs and
as automation became more widespread,
humans shifted into service jobs and
then only a few moments ago in human
history, the information age happened.
Suddenly the rules were different.
How jobs are now being taken over by
machines much faster than they were in the
past. That's worrying of course,
but innovation will clearly save us,
right? While new inflammation,
age industries are booming,
they are creating fewer
and fewer new jobs.
In 1979 general motors employed more
than 800,000 workers and made about 11
billion US dollars.
In 2012 Google made about 14 billion US
dollars while employing 58,000 people.
You may not like this comparison,
but Google is an example of what
created new jobs in the past.
Innovative new industries, old, innovative
industries are running out of steam.
Just look at cars.
When they became a thing 100 years ago,
they created huge industries,
cause transformed our way of life,
our infrastructure and our cities.
Millions of people found jobs
either directly or indirectly,
decades of investment cap.
This momentum going today.
This process is largely complete
innovation in the car industry.
It does not create as many jobs as it
used to while the electric cars are great
and all, they won't create
millions of new jobs. But wait,
what about the,
some technologists argue that the Internet
isn't innovation on a power with the
introduction of electricity.
If we go with this comparison,
we see how our modern innovation
differs from the old one.
The Internet created new industries but
they're not creating enough jobs to keep
up with population growth or to compensate
for the industry as the Internet is
killing.
At its peak in 2004 blockbuster had
84,000 employees and made 6 billion US
dollars in revenue in 2016 Netflix had
4,500 employees and made $9 billion in
revenue or take us for example,
with a full time team of just 12 people
courts cause angst reaches millions of
people. The TV station with
the same amount of viewers
needs way more employees.
Innovation in the information age doesn't
equate to the creation of enough new
jobs,
which would be bad enough on its own,
but now a new wave of automation and
a new generation of machines is slowly
taking over.
To understand this,
we need to understand ourselves first.
Human progress is based
on the division of Labor.
As we advanced over thousands of years,
our jobs became more and more specialized.
While even our smartest machines
are bad at doing complicated jobs.
They are extremely good at doing
narrowly defined and predictable tasks.
This is what destroyed factory jobs,
but look at a complex job long and hard
enough and you'll find that it's ready.
Just many narrowly defined and
predictable tasks. One after another.
Machines are on the brink of becoming so
good at breaking down complex jobs into
many predictable ones
that for a lot of people,
there will be no further
room to specialize.
We are on the verge of being out competed.
Digital machines do this
via machine learning,
which enables them to acquire
information and skills by analyzing data.
This makes them become better at
something through the relationships they
discover machines teach themselves.
We make this possible by giving a
computer a lot of data about the thing we
wanted to become better at.
Show a machine,
all the things you bought online and it
will slowly learn what to recommend to
you so you buy more things.
Machine learning is now meeting more of
its potential because in recent years
humans have started to
gather data about everything,
behavior, weather patterns, medical
records, communication systems,
travel data and of course
data about what we do at work.
What we've created by
accident is a huge library.
Machines can use to learn how humans
do things and learn to do them better.
These digital machines might be
the biggest job killer of all.
They can be replicated instantly
and for free when they improve.
You don't need to invest
in big metal things.
You can just use the new and they
have the ability to get better fast.
How fast. If your work involves
complex work on a computer as a day,
you might be out of work even sooner
than the people who still have jobs in
factories.
There are actual real world examples of
how this transition might be happening.
A San Francisco company offers a
project management software for big
corporations,
which is supposed to eliminate middle
management positions when it's hard for a
new project.
The software first asides which jobs
can be automated and precisely where it
needs actual professional humans.
It then helps assemble a team of
freelancers over the Internet.
The software then distributes tasks to
the humans and controls the policy of the
work tracking individual performance
until the project is complete.
Okay, this doesn't sound too bad.
Well, this machine is killing one job.
It creates jobs for
freelancers, right? Well,
as the freelancers complete their
tasks, learning algorithms, trek them,
and gather data about their work
and which tasks it consists of.
So what's actually happening is that the
freelance is on teaching a machine how
to replace them.
On average,
this software reduces costs by about 50%
in the first year and by another 25% in
the second year.
This is only one example of many.
There are machines and programs getting
as good or better than humans in all
kinds of fields,
from pharmacists to analysts,
journalists to radiologists,
caches of bank tellers,
all the unskilled worker flipping burgers.
All of these jobs won't disappear over
night with fewer and fewer humans will be
doing them. We'll discuss a
few cases and a followup video,
but while jobs disappearing is bad,
it's only half of the story.
It's not enough to substitute
old jobs with new ones.
We need to be generating new jobs
constantly because the world population is
growing. In the past, we have
solved this through innovation,
but since 1973 the generation of new jobs
in the U S has begun to shrink and the
first decade of the 21st century who was
the first one where the total amount of
jobs in the u s did not grow for the
first time in a country that needs to
create up to 150,000 new jobs per month
just to keep up with population growth.
This is bad news.
This is also starting to
affect standards of living.
In the past it was seen as obvious
that with the rising productivity,
more and better jobs would be created,
but the numbers tell a different story.
In 1998 us workers worked a
total of 194 billion hours.
Over the course of the next 15 years,
their output increased by 42% but in
2013 the amount of hours worked by US
workers was 194 billion hours.
What this means is that despite
productivity growing drastically,
thousands of new businesses opening up
and the u s population growing by over 40
million, there was no growth at all in
the number of hours worked in 15 years.
At the same time,
wages for new university graduates and
the U s have been declining for the past
decade.
One up to 40% of new graduates are forced
to take on jobs that don't require a
degree.
Productivity is separating
from human labor.
The nature of innovation
in the information age is
different from everything we
encountered before.
This process started years ago
and there's already well underway.
Even without new disruptions like self
driving cars or robot accountants.
It looks like automation
is different this time.
This time the machines might really take
our jobs and our economies are based on
the premise that people consume, but if
fewer and fewer people have decent work,
who will be doing all the consuming?
Are we producing evermore cheaply only
to arrive at a point where too few people
can actually buy all our staff and
services all will the future see a tiny
minority of the cigarettes who own the
machines dominating the rest of us and
does our future ready has
to be that grim won't.
We were fairly dark in this video.
It's far from certain that
things will turn out negatively.
The information age and modern automation,
it could be a huge opportunity to change
human society and reduce poverty and
inequality drastically. It could be
a seminal moment in human history.
We'll talk about this potential and
possible solutions like a universal basic
income.
In part two of this video's areas we
need to think big and fast because one
thing's for sure the machines are
not coming. They are all ready here.
This video,
it took us about $900 to make and we'd
been working on it for over nine months.
Projects like this one would
not be possible without
your support on [inaudible]
dot com if you want to help us out and
get a personal codes cause I was bird in
return,
that would be really useful.
We based much of this video
on two very good books,
the rise of the robots and
the second machine age.
You can find links to both of them in the
video description. Highly recommended.
Also,
we made a little robot poster.
You can buy it and a lot of
other stuff in our DF. Tba Shot.
This video is part of a larger series
about how technology is already changing
and will change human life forever.
If you want to continue watching.
We have a few playlists.